bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonal TV pour ce Championnat du Monde
2014 Carlsen Anand partie numéro 10
Anand est mené d'un point il reste trois
parties Anand va avoir deux fois les
blancs cette 10e et la 12e et une fois
les noir dans la prochaine dans la 11e
c'est parti que va préparer Anand pour
essayer de revenir au score D4 donc là
il varie pas Carsen joue cavalier F6
C4 G6 donc la Carsen revient dans les
variantes avec G6 qu' a avait joué en
début de match est-ce qu'il va nous
rejouer la Grunfeld on va voir ça tout
tout de suite après CER C3 oui D5 c'est
la c'est bien la Grunfeld il a pas joué
une est indienne il joue la grunfield et
là Anand rappelez-vous avait fait une
variante à la base de pion pran cavalier
pran il avait joué fou des de un coup
peu usité mais avec une partie
intéressante où il avait il avait du jeu
là Carsen après cavalier F3 et sans
doute surpris puisque Anan ne rejoue
joue pas cette variante mais c'était
peut-être il avait joué ça à N pour
peut-être attendre le bon moment pour
sortir ses préparation maison fou
G7 dame B3 voilà
donc une pression maximale sur D5 et une
petite pression sur B7 aussi ce qui fait
que le fou C8 peut pas bouger facilement
sinon il B7 qui tombe donc là le plus
simple pour les Noirs c'est de prendre
C4 d' prend mais en se faisant on a plus
qu'un pion contre deux au centre c'est
ça l'idée les Noirs laissent les blancs
installer au centre avec des pions et
l'idée des Noirs c'est d'attaquer très
vite ce centre et puissamment hein pour
pas laisser les blancs le temps de
souffler petit rock on s'installe au
centre avec4 cavalier A6 logique bien
que curieux parce qu'on on conseille de
pas sortir les cavaliers à la bande en
général parce qu'ils sont moins actifs
mais là en fait c'est une très bonne
case pour ce cavalier parce que et bien
il laisse le fou C8 contrôler la case 6
dont on va voir qu'elle est cruciale et
aussi la case G4 donc je peux me
développer soit6 soit en G4 et et en cas
de E6 pour les Noirs donc je contrôle
avec le fou alors si je viens en D7 je
contrôle plus et en plus en A6
je prépare la poussée C5 qui peut être
extrêmement forte fou2 et là tout de
suite C5 voilà alors on peut se dire ben
oui mais les blancs ici peuvent prendre
en C5 certes les blancs peuvent prendre
en C5 c'est net mais les Noirs dans ce
caslà gagnent du développement ça peut
aller très très très très vite regardez
fa 6 attaque la dame où va la dame si on
veut garder le le contrôle du pion euh
si on si on joue à Dame à 4 cavalier
prend C5 attaque la dame et on
attaque4 c'est quasiment déjà foutu
parce qu'on a pas roquet et tout va
tomberin il faut jouer dame B5 pour
essayer de garder le pion mais après
simplement un coup évident comme tour C8
le pion là va tomber on peut pas le
protéger c'est pas facile hein un coup
comme euh fou E3 est possible
encore pour euh protéger C5 mais
simplement regardez un coup simple très
fort pour les noirs très simple cavalier
G4 libère la puissance du Fou G7 attaque
le défenseur de C5 et c'est fini ça va
tout tout va tomber imaginons que les
Blancs jouent un coup comme dam prend B7
c'est envisageable hein ben regardez les
Noirs prendraient d'abord cal E3 menace
une fourchette ici puis on prend forcé
et maintenant caler prend C5 voire même
euh oui CER prend C5 attaque la dame
ça c'est quand même c'est c'est une
poubelle c'est fini la partie est finie
les noirs on la paire de fou regardez
qui tape à fond sur l'eld dam C pions
centraux c'est une catastrophe enfin
voilà voyez comme la position est
transformée très très vite donc on n pas
le temps avec les blancs de jouer au
guignol avec C5 D5 voilà D5 on garde la
puissance des pions d'où l'idée
maintenant d'avoir joué cavalier 6 le
fou cont le 6 donc on peut jouer
l'attaque
centrale immédiate E6 normal petit rock
puionion prend D5 puision prend D5 ce
pion est à la fois un pion passé fort au
centre mais c'est un pion isolé il a pas
de pion pour se protéger donc il peut
saavarer soit fort soit faible tour 8 de
Carsen très puissant je développe mes
pièces je contrôle le centre j'attaque
le fou E2 VO a un coup très très très
puissant on attend pour avant de placer
le fou C8 fou G5 dansant développement
du Fou vous allez voir en deux temps je
cloue le cavalier F6 qui est quand même
un attaquant de D5 c'est quand même
assez désagréable le coup suivant des
noirs est classique H6 et là en général
sur H6 on peut jouer soit fou H4 c'est
connu on veut pousser les Noirs à jouer
G5 ça faaiblir un peu pourquoi pas
euh mais on prend pas parce que si on
prend on donne la paire de fou au noir
et comme la position est quand même semi
ouverte là pour pas dire ouverte bon
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle si on donne
la paire de fou qui est quand même
toujours des pièces de longue portée
faut pas oublier si on a la paire de fou
l'avantage c'est que on contrôle à la
fois des cases blanches et les cases
noires et c'est puissant c'est fou dans
une position où ils ont de quoi
s'exprimer ils ont des belles diagonales
à leur disposition donc on donne pas
hein non non on fait fou E3 voilà on a
développé le fou en deux temps l'intérêt
d'avoir poussé les Noirs H6 c'est que ça
c'est une cible et le fou attaque H6
donc si ce fou sort il y a H6 qui va
tomber voilà on a une cible fou
F5 et là tour à D1 logique voilà t D1
surprotège notre pion fort il est bien
protégé il est soutenu par une tour
c'est c'est parfait et là Carsen en
profite maintenant pour jouer cavalier4
et voilà déjà proposition d'échange le
Fou est libéré voyez et d'où l'intérêt
d'avoir sorti toutes ces pièces en F5 on
contrôl E4 aussi et voilà proposition
d'échange on n pas trop trop le choix il
faut
échanger
foupr clarsen fait foupr il aurait pu
aussi envisager de faire tour pr attaque
la dame mais faut prer pas si mal ça
attaque
D5 c'est surtout ça le Fou est au centre
il attaque des5 c'est pas il attaque pas
vraiment le cavalier on veut pas donner
la paire de fou au blanc en tout cas pas
facilement dame C1 logique je protège B2
du Fou G7 et j'attaque le pion H6 alors
là on peut envisager une défense passive
r H7 mais ça laisse au blanc le la
possibilité de s'activer on peut jouer
fou B5 ou à la tour hein r H7 fou B5 où
va la tour si la tour vient7 D6 et où va
tour toujours on commence à être très
ennuyé donc dame F6 Carsen est beaucoup
plus fort voilà parce que en échange de
l'attaque sur H6 j'attaque B2 moi aussi
j'ai une batterie et en même temps je
libère la case des8 pour une tour voyez
donc ce coup est quand même plus fort
qu'un coup passif comme R H7 alors là
NAND faut pas oublier qu'il essit quand
même de gagner hein parce que c'est un
championnat du monde il faut jouer
dynamique hein donc il prend quand même
le pion H6 hein pas de problème évidment
l'idée des Noirs c'est pas de faire
foupran et laisser la dame s'installer
en H6 à côté du roi il prend B2 et il
propose un cherge de dame comme on l'a
vu dans ce dans ce match Carsen est très
content d'échanger les dames il s'en
sort toujours magnifiquement bien en
finale dam prend fou prend et maintenant
là un moment déjà crucial pour Anan
possibilité de jouer D6 ou de jouer
d'autres coups comme celui qu' a fait
bon mais DC cétait envisageable hein
c'est c'est un coup bon mais qu'il a dû
préparer et peut-être que ce qu'il a vu
c'était mieux il qu'il a tenté cavalier
G5 intéressant attaque le fou voilà
attaque le fou que fait que font les
Noirs alors à noter ici que il y a une
petite variante qu'il faut absolument
voir c'est la possibilité de jouer fou
prang G2 pourquoi parce que c'est
surprenant qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
coup mais faut pas oublier que la tour
ici attaque donc si roi prend tour prend
alors pourquoi R ne fait pas fa prend G2
ah ben parce que ça marche pas quand
même parce qu'on fait d'abord fou prend
cavalier et donc si les Noirs reprennent
et ben on prend le fou et on a une pièce
de plus ou voyez et oui et si les Noirs
disent ben je prends d'abord en F1 ben
simplement on reprend du Fou et on a une
pièce de
plus voilà donc on va après par exemple
fou G7 fou prend roi prend on a fou et
cavalier contre tour avec un pion passé
c'est avantage blanc donc là Carsen ne
tombe pas dans ce piège grossier hein ça
marche pas il y a foupr foupr à 6 en cas
de sortie de ce fou
euh donc il fait le plus subtile fou4
très fort très fort la case des4 est
forte elle est protégée par C5 ce fou
central bon bien sûr atta2 g mais c'est
pas tellement ça il empêche la tour de
protéger D5 donc D5 est
attaqué cé de prendre ce
fou4 n plus attaqu et après fou F3 ce
fou tient solidement le pion D5 et en
plus on va viser B7 donc le coup suivant
des noir est un peu obligé
t t 7 pour protéger ici B7 puisque D6
peut arriver très
vite il le fait quand même un D6 Carsen
joue tour des7 continue à avoir un œil
sur B7 bloque le pion D6 et là
Anand
joue fou
F4 il aurait pu aussi tenter tour 1
tour1 et aussi aurait été intéressant
mais bon pourquoi pas fou F4 euh alors
tour on été intéressant parce qu'en cas
de tour prend D6 on prend B7 attaque la
tour est obligé de jouer ou VO la tour
bon ass c'est pas vraiment attaqué
puisque si on prend D6 la tour protège
hein mais bon fu F4 on surprotège D6 et
on peut menacer maintenant tour enfin
menacer entre guillemets tout et là joli
coup de Carsen mais tendu hein cavalier
B4 attaque
A2 et alors là Anand a joué un coup qui
semble un peu passif c'est que ce qu'on
a dit tout à l'heure le cou H7 était
passif il joue le coup tour des deux bon
c'est bien ça protège à deux mais mais
c'est passif c'est-à-dire que ça ça ne
menace rien donc ça laisse les Noirs se
regrouper au lieu de quoi le coup A3
semblait plus plus
dynamique hein donc ici un coup comme A3
là était possible attaque le cavalier ou
va le cavalier et c'est pas si simple
hein là cavalier aurait pu regardez ils
auraient pu Carsen aurait pu jouer le
coup cavalier C2 attaque à 3 que font
les
que font les blancs ici bah c'est pas
simple A3
attaqué alors une possibilité c'est de
jouer simplement regardez tour D3 je
protège à 3 et ce cavalier a un problème
tour FC1 menace et là Caren avait sans
doute une défense très joli c'est fou
G7 mais pourquoi il joue fou G7 que
j'avais le fou cétait pour empêcher la
tour d'attaquer des6 certes ben on va le
remplacer par le cavalier magnifique
parce que ce cavalier sera aussi bien
placé voir même mieux que le fou c'est
sa meilleure case au cavalier en D4 le
fou c'est une pièce à longue portée bon
il est bien au centre mais il est pas
plus mal loin pour attaquer des des
pions des pions si on joue cavalier D4
on voit bien qu'un plan à base de fou F8
va ramasser le fou euh le pion D6 hein
on peut même doubler les tours
maintenant et ce D6 il va finir par
tomber hein donc voyez hein il avait
quand même une possibilité mais c'était
quand même une variante intéressante
avec des possibilités là euh les blancs
auraient pu quand même continuer par
tour D5 attaque C5 vous voyez qu'on peut
on laisse pas faire caler D4 comme ça et
là ben Carsen aurait pu euh tenter
cavalier prend à3 mais ici simplement
tour prend C5 et se cavalé a des
problèmes regardez il est complètement
complètement pris et en plus on
éliminant le pion C5 on a libéré la
colonne C on a les tours actives on va
jouer tour FC1 on peut jouer tour C7
problème le B7 va tomber puis A7 et là
les blancs sont hyper bien donc c'était
possible tour des5 ici que font les
noirs et ben il y a peut-être encore une
défense simplement jouer cavalier
D4 on laisse prendre C5 parce que là on
attaque
F3 là sur par exemple sur tour prend C5
ah oui al non c'est pas qu'on attaque F3
c'est surtout qu'on a une menace très
intéressante c'est simplement c'est
calios 6 voilà c'est encore plus fort
attaque la tour et F4 si les blanc
jouent tour C7 en espérant cavalier
prend pion prend avec un pion passé
extrêmement fort puisque maintenant le
fou F3 va prendre B7 ça a l'air même
gagnant pour les blancs mais ça marche
pas parce que tour C7 on fait tour prend
puis on prend et après on prend le fou
et C7 va tomber puisquil est sur
noir quoi que non même pas je sais pas
si ça marche si ça marche ou non ça
marche non non on peut pas on peut pas
faire ça tour C7 sur tour prend non ça
marche pas tour prend pion prend le pion
C7 est protégé par le fou et maintenant
si cavalier prend F4 qui est quasiment
forcé pour essayer en fait on fait fou
prend B7 non ou même mieux tour
D1 ici tour D1 menace tour des8 échec et
ça ramasse tout que font les
noirs
sur cavalier E6 qui est possible
simplement maintenant on fait fou prend
B7 la tour est attaquée si cavalier
prend fou prend cavalier prend tour
échec je ramasse en plus le cavalier
c'est fini j'ai une qualité de plus avec
une position gagnante et là c'est fini
il y a la dame voilà donc ça gagne pour
les blancs alors attention donc là c'est
intéressantin donc là d prend C7 euh
alors tour prend C5 est pas voyez à
cause de cavalier 6 ça a l'air de
marcher quand même hein alors là que
font les Noirs voyez donc cétait
intéressant cette variante voilà donc là
anande ben malheureusement il rentre pas
là-dedans voilà il fait le coup qui a
l'air moins fort tour des deux hein
alors à moins que bien sûr les analyses
plus précises he réute là il faudrait
aller dans les détails mais bon va pas
faire l'analyse des champions du monde
ici donc là ça permet à Carsen voyez
comme j'ai dit de de de respirer et de
jouer un coup de développement tour E8
voilà ça y est tour E8 donc on peut plus
venir en E1 on n pas de colonne pour
pénétrer ce pion D6 comme on l'a dit il
est passé mais on voit bien qu'il est
tenu que par le fou et que ça va être
dur tour C1 bon il développe quand même
sa tour àand attention cette tour si
elle sort il y a mat du couloir hein
attention donc c'est un développement
mais il faudra faire quelque chose et là
tour E6 très joli coup tranquille voilà
commence à mettre pression sur
D6 alors attention parce que les noirs
peuvent aussi avoir un autre plan c'est
de jouer
F6 G5 ou valfou par exemple en G3 et
après F5 F4 et ces deux pions empêchent
le fou de contrôler D6 qui va
tomber donc c'est pourquoi anant joue le
coup H4 et non pas H3 voilà H4 empêche
toute idée à base de F 6 G5 en cas de F6
G5 boum je prends et en échange du pion
D6 ben je gagne un pion du roi donc
voilà H4 est fort et là ben Carsen joue
un très joli coup très simple F5 voilà
on élimine le ce fameux fou qui tient
des6 puisque si ce fout tombe bon bien
sûr je vais après fou prend tour prend
j'attaque plus tout de suite mais quand
je vais revenir en E6 bah D6 sera
difficilement défendable à moins de tout
miser tout mettre toutes les tours
dessus mais bon euh il reste ça serait
dire que les Blancs seront vissés à la
défense du
pion et là bon ben Anand aurait pu quand
même essayer encore peut-être un coup
comme fou G4 pour poser la question à la
tour et forcer la réponse F5 voilà
revenir en F3 et maintenant ben si
euh
tour6
regardez c'est possible et dans ce
cas-là on joue à a 3 le cavalier bouge
et fou des5 clouage
A3 cavalier bouge par exemple en je sais
pas moi en C6 tiens pour viser des4 mais
ça marche pas hop
clouage coucou c'est terminé on récupère
la qualité donc là on peut jouer le gain
on a tro contre de bon on a TR contre
ici mais on a la qualité avec une belle
position et c'est sans doute enfin c'est
avantage blanc avec des belles ch belles
chances de gain donc là non fou prend5
tour
prend5 fou G4 était intéressant ici
voilà ou
simplement attendre que les Noirs jouent
tour6 est-ce qu'on pouvait tenter un
coup comme par exemple G3 pour
consolider à commencer à envisager
d'amener le roi au centre quelque chose
comme ça sur tour E6 bah le pion C5
tombe si les Noirs jouent B6 on peut
mais dans ce CASL on contrôle moins bien
à 6 après à3 et bien le cavalier bouge
et fou 6 alors là si les noirs attaquent
par tour 6 qui semble
logique bah il y a C5 qui
tomb par exemple
tour pr C5 les Noirs se vange sur D6
d'accord mais là dans ce cas-là on fait
simplement tour prend D6 tour prendre D6
et il y a le pion B7 qui tombe voire
même on peut prendre avec la tour voire
on peut jouer même tour tour C7 aussi
qui a l'air très bon très bon puisquon
attaque toujours mais en plus on a mis
la tour sur la 7e et ça c'est toujours
bien parce que ça va limiter l'action du
roi noir et puis plus tard peut-être que
le fou il sera sur cette diagonale là et
on attaquera F7 voyez donc là on a une
position très intéressante pour les
blancs une finale technique mais
avec avec très certainement avantage
blanc puisque on va les blancs les noirs
peuvent prendre à2 on va prendre B7 il y
aura des pions des deux côtés de l'aile
si le pion noir tombe il y aura trois
contre de de avec un fou contre un
cavalier qui c'est sans doute de belles
chances de gain pour les blancs
peut-être pas gagnant mais il va falloir
défendre ça sans faire de faute et ça
risque être très très
difficile donc là il y avait quand même
des choses à faire ici il y avait des
choses à faire alors là un N il joue un
coup peut-être pas terrible terrible
puis qu'il fait fou prend B7 il donne le
fou il donne le fou avec bah la suite
est forcée hein quasiment c'est tour
prend et maintenant il veut jouer D7
on c'est bien ça menace de dame mais
simplement bien sûr on joue cavalier
C6 et là bah il a pas trop le choix
parce que là le cavalier menace de venir
en D8 hein et bon fait quoi quoi alors
une possibilité pour Anand aurait été de
tenter peut-être
ici un coup comme
F4 F4 pour pourquoi parce que je veux
faire je veux perturber cette tour qu a
afin de me venger sur C5 ici de prendre
C5 me venger de prendre
C5 donc là je me venge pas mais prendre
bon parce que là à tout moment je peux
faire dame et récupérer le cavalier bien
sûr mais je peux essayer de gagner plus
donc là que font les noir pas évident on
peut tenter quand même tour F5 et
maintenant
G4 tour pr F4 on prend
C5 là les Noirs ramassent tout prend G4
échec par
exemple je on dire F tien ah ouiutre
tour qui peut venir en plus c'est
pénible
tchec2 tour B4 alors là maintenant
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on fait tour
prend
C6 on peut faire
échec
ro3 ah oui j'ai compris on peut plus
bouger là
échec
F2 et là on peut faire un échec
perpétuel avec celle-là par exemple le
RO blanc peut pas trop s'en aller et si
on met la ah oui si si si si on met si
on va là par exemple simplement oui on
revient en fait on revient ici en fait
ici sur ça on peut faire échec roi E2
ouais à la fin on est obligé de donner
la tour ici par exemple3 et simplement
on prend la tour 2 qui attaque ici on n
pas le temps donc par ex si on fait roi
prend on perd le pion et si on fait roi
prend tour on se prend un échec suivi de
tour prend D7 voilà donc voyez que là on
peut pas vraiment tenter ces manipes là
ça marche pas la contre-attaque noire
est trop forte le roi serait trop à nu
si on donne les pions donc il reste plus
que
D8 cavalier prend tour prend échec ro G7
tour D2 et Anand propose nul que Carsen
accepte 32 coups à une partie tendue une
belle partie beaucoup de théories
Grunfeld une préparation d'Anand alors
il a peut-être raté quelque chose dans
dans sa préparation pe se souvenait pas
tout à fait exactement de la variante
peut-être que A3 était dans sa
préparation le fameux coup qu'on a vu
c'est possible he des fois les
préparations vont très loin mais Carsen
a réussi semblet-il sans trop de souci
quand même à se développer et à avoir
une position équilibrée qu'il a su gérer
sans sans paniquer et sans faire
d'erreur donc c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour Anan quand même puisque ça
ça l'aide pas à revenir au
score la parti
euh fait que maintenant le
match on va regarder ça tout de suite
est de nouveau en faveur de
Carsen enfin toujours en faveur de
Carsen
voilà donc on est à la 10e Carsen mène
toujours après avoir gagné la 2e et la
6e il mène toujours 2-1 hein en terme de
victoire il reste deux parties voilà
donc bon mais les deux dernières parties
risquent d'être de la même veine très
tendu et peut-être même qu'avec les
Noirs Anand va tenter de jouer quelque
chose d'extrêmement pointu on peut on
peut tout on peut s'attendre à tout hein
pourquoi pas une défense àquine pourquoi
pas n'importe quoi une défense
pourquoi pas une défense scandinave avec
4 D5 est-ce que Carsen va pas tenter D4
pour essayer de perturber Anand et dans
cette partie ne pas jouer au 4
euh pour éviter toute toute préparation
et sortir à N de sa préparation on verra
ça il peut craquer aussi faut voir ça va
être ça va se jouer au NIR en général là
à ce niveau-là maintenant c'est les ner
c'est pas la technique voilà donc pour
cette 10e partie du championnat du monde
Carsen Anand qui donc est nul et Anand
quand même qui a fait une belle partie
tendue voyez extrêmement difficile quand
même à de voir des il y a pas de faute
véritable he c'était des choix
positionnels et il y a pas eu de faute
vraiment du côté du côté noir donc
Carsen n pas réussi à enfin Anan n'a pas
réussi à déstabiliser Carsen non plus
sur la 10e voilà bien rendez-vous donc à
la 11e partie sur diagonal TV merci de
me re sur cette émission pour la suite
de ce championnat du monde 2014 Carsen
Anand avec le suspense qui augmente au
fur et à mesure que la fin du match
approche merci de m'avoir suivi au
revoir à bientôt sur diagonal
TV